des poèmes déclamés entre les fruits et
les fleurs une scène quelque peu
insolite pour lancer le printemps des
poètes thème retenu cette année ardeurs
au pluriel
un thème que la poétesse québécoise
nicole brossard connaît bien
allons du côté des sanglots langer notre
ardeur dans la question et laisse
cerises de mes ardeurs seyant faut
toujours surtout lorsqu'on est en poésie
c'est la motivation c'est la passion
c'est la figure ans
je sais que des brèdes écrivent dans le
grand calme dans l'anxiété moi je pense
que j'écris plus tôt je suis plutôt du
côté de l'ardeur tout naturellement
c'est donc sous le signe de toutes les
ardeurs que se déroulera cette 20e
édition
coordonné par les itinéraires poétique
le lieu choisi pour le lancement de la
manifestation n'était pas anodin le
théme ardeurs est un thème très général
on va dire très générique c'est à dire
qu'on peut y mettre ce qu'on veut de
dans un vote pouvait parler de l'ardeur
l'ardeur au travail ces gens qui sont là
pendant des journées entières sur des
marchés ils ont intérêt à avoir une
sacrée ardeurs intérieure et une envie
de voilà deux de faire quelque chose de
leur vie pour venir sur ce marché une
quinzaine de comédiens est intervenu sur
l'ensemble du marché pour dire des
textes et distribuer des cartes postales
sur lesquels avaient été imprimées des
poèmes
je trouve que de faire sortir la poésie
en vie pour tout le monde c'est super
voilà tout le monde peut en profiter et
découvrir un petit peu que la poésie
c'est toute la vie et tous les jours il
ya toujours un point qui a des choses à
vous dire